From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Do we want to change discs?
When we reach sort of natural partying spots, because these are digital files, we'll stop to save the files.
So they don't get too long, because the one will interrupt you.
I'll start by giving you an introduction for the tape, but then we'll just want to write it.
Today is Sunday April 14, 2013. This is David Cline for the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
The Smithsonian Institution's National Museum of African American History and Culture of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
And again, this is David Cline, interviewer. I'm here with John Bishop, videographer, and I'm very happy to have with us today Gloria Claudette Grinnell.
And thank you so much for being part of this project. We very much appreciate your time.
Thank you for coming.
So if I could ask you, if we could just start with your childhood, if you could tell us a little bit about your family and where you were raised, and the environment that you came out of.
Okay. I'll go back to my grandparents if I may, because in a way it was a civil rights type activity.
My grandfather, this is stories that were told to me, and I asked my cousin about it because he is older than I, and he says it's true.
My grandfather had $500 invested in the stock market, and of course he lost it. This is when people were jumping out the window and so forth.
And my grandparents were teachers. I think he taught languages and music, and I don't know what my grandmother taught.
But they moved from Virginia to Philadelphia. And that started the family, split the family, because my grandparents couldn't get a job. They said they didn't hire black teachers in Philly.
They had black children going to integrated schools, but no black teachers.
So my grandmother took in washing, and my grandfather refused to do that type work. And the family actually split. They were together physically, but not together.
The older kids went to college in the family, and they were teachers at two oldest ones.
The youngest kid was sent to school by the middle children who did not go to college. They had to work to help pay.
So, but again, here we go about the color line thing. I was born in D.C. My mother was born in Virginia, and my dad was born in Maryland.
And when I was three, oh, my parents divorced when I was a baby. And my dad took the boy, my mother took the girl, and remarried, moved to San Francisco.
So from the age of three on, I grew up in San Francisco. Then she remarried again, and moved to San Diego. And I ended up at Virginia Union University, which one of my great, great grandparents was on the board at Virginia.
And it was great to know that my great, great, great, grandparent had helped to start the school.
So, if we talk a little bit more about your childhood growing up on the West Coast, before you went to experience Virginia.
And what were the sort of racial dynamics of life in both Southern and also the Northern California?
Okay, growing up in San Francisco, I lived in what is now called the Western Addition. It was called the Western Addition back in those days.
You know, and I tried to think, was it full of black people? I think as a child, you probably don't even know. And I guess that's where the black people lived.
Then we moved to the Presidio.
And I went to St. Dominic's own Pine and Steiner, if you know where that is. It was all white. I was only black child.
And every day I used to pray, I hope the nun doesn't slap me this morning. She would walk down as we were praying outside in the morning and slap me.
And I, we prayed to God, God, I've done something wrong. Please help me. You know, I didn't know what I had done wrong. Never did.
And I used to get Fs. All my papers were F's. And I, I was in the second grade or third grade.
And my mother said, you need to bring your papers home and I started crying. She said, what's wrong? I said, mom, I'm dumb. I get all F's.
She said, that's okay. Bring them home anyway. She collected that many papers about an inch and marched me up to the school. And she says, why are these marked wrong?
There's nothing wrong on most of the pay. I didn't know I was bright. And the nun started crying. And my mom said, go outside and play. I said, mom, I'm not allowed to play. I have to go to church doing recess and lunch.
What are the other kids for outplay?
And my mother says, I think you better go outside. I don't know what she said to the nun, but after that, the smartest girl and I in class were vying for grades.
And then then stopped slapping me. I didn't tell my mother she slapped me.
So that was my experience there. I went to a public school first called Presidio. And a little boy said, a little white boy. A little boy said that he couldn't hold my hand because his mother said he couldn't hold a hand of niggers.
So I went home and asked my mother was I a nigger because I didn't know. I knew it was something bad because he couldn't hold my hand.
So that was probably the first time you heard that.
Yeah. That was my experience there. I had heard of other experiences. I remember we owned a mom and pops grocery store, which is typical in San Francisco.
You know, they have a safe way, but generally you have little stories. And a man came in and my parents never talked in front of me.
And then I heard them whispering that he's a teacher, but he can only substitute because he has a dishonable discharge.
Because during World War II, he jumped off a ship refusing to fight because he said, why should he fight for America?
Freeing other countries, whether he's not free here. I remember that was saying that.
And then I remember my mother trying to get a job and they told her you join the union first and you can get the job.
And the union says get the job first and vice versa. This went on. And I remember my mother crying, but not in front of us, but I do remember.
So little things, subtle things. You know, you know, Santa Monica had a big rope across their beach, you know, unofficially, but it's there.
You know, teaching jobs, only teaching the black area. You know, I mean, it was there. It's still there, but.
So when had your parents at all prepared you for what it would be like, as you got ready to go across the country.
No, nobody could prepare you. You didn't know the first thing I did when I got in town. I sat down at the soda fountain. I said, gee, I want to banal split. I'll never forget this.
One strawberry, one vanilla. And if you don't have black walnut, please put another strawberry, no chocolate and and strawberry syrup on top and whipped cream in that.
I always get that. The lady went away to make it and she came back and she says, oh, we can't serve you. I said, oh, are you out?
She says, no, and I said, oh, I remember saying, oh, I said, oh, three times it shocked me. You know, I couldn't get a banal split because I'm black sitting at the counter.
I wasn't thinking. I knew you couldn't, but I wasn't thinking. I just sat down.
Yeah. Yeah. Had you had experiences like that in California? They are overt, not covert. You can fill them. Yeah. Yeah.
But there it was just. Yeah. Well, I have been asked when I went to high school, my cousin was Filipino. And she says, Claudette, I want you, my middle name is Claudette.
I want you to come with me to the Filipino picnic. I said, no, I'm not Filipino. I said, you are. She says, come with me. So I went and I took my date.
And when we got to the place outside of San Francisco, the guy said on the on the gate, I have to let you in. Are you sure you want to come?
So I've had that type thing or places in you people can come in. Do you think you're going to be happy? You know, yeah.
Kind of coded or presented. Right. Right.
May I ask why you decided to go to a black, traditionally black? Yeah. My mother thought it would be good for me.
I know. But you know, I think a black, I think I should have gone to Howard. I mean, don't get me wrong for genuine union was great. But I should have been in the city.
You know, because it was too much learning at one time, being in the south and the mentality and.
So what was that that like when we talked about those people, but what was that the indoctrination till?
Well, I didn't like anybody, the black people and the white people.
It was it. First of all, I was young and I thought I knew everything and I didn't. I didn't know anything.
And this is what you're you got?
In the 50s, 50, 59 around then. But you know, as a young person, you're very ignorant, but you don't know it.
I thought I knew everything. And when I went there, I couldn't understand why the white people treated the blacks away. They were treated. And why the blacks allowed it.
I even got angry with some of the black people for not sitting in the kids. And I didn't understand. I do now. If they had sat in, they wouldn't have had done on the table that night because their parents would have been fired.
I had no idea.
So what was Virginia Union University like in terms of a sort of a consciousness of black consciousness that was among.
Or even where there are teachers that were talking about these issues.
Yeah, I you know, I believe people it was a way of life. And they knew how to live within the system.
I'm not saying it was comfortable for them, but I think they had a black society, which was a way of living.
I remember Dr. Johnson, who was my favorite instructor there, Bob Johnson. He had two PhDs, I think.
I think he got his first when he was 18, I'm not sure. Very bright man. He used to play in a quartet. I don't know what he played violin or something.
He said one night he was driving home. He used to tell jokes in class. And he had this white woman in car. Then he thought, oh my God, I'm going to be killed. He was always saying things like that.
I don't know. I don't remember. I'm so dag on old. I don't remember.
So I'm going to be asking questions about this. The city has been obviously curious what prefigured those, what kind of conversations you may have been having amongst yourselves as students.
Well, we were having meetings as you know, Charles and Pinkett, what's his name? Charles Sherrod /, I think. We're the leaders. And we were always having meetings about that.
Charles, you're off.
Can you remember what some of those meetings were like?
No, I can't. I'm telling you, being old is a son of a gun.
But I thought the world was going to change, though. I was so naive. Gosh. I remember going, the policeman, the police person was very nice to me. I remember when we were arrested, he held my hand and helped me up into the Paddy wagon.
And I thought that was so nice. Am I aren't called me? She says, I see you on the news. You're being helped into the Paddy wagon.
And you mentioned that there are some students who didn't participate that you were angry with.
I was angry with them because I felt they lived in Virginia they should. But then after meeting, I met one girl at the reunion.
I'm cold and I'm kind of freezing. Can you stop a minute? Yeah.
Okay. I met a lady at the 50th year reunion. Well, she was in the sit-in, so every day I knew her. But they needed pictures. I didn't remember anyone. They needed pictures when they were young.
Because I haven't seen these people in 50 years. And we were sitting at the table and tears were coming down her eyes. I felt like crying too, but I don't cry in front of people.
And she said that her father was fired. They had to move out of state. She had to drop out of school. I don't know if she ever finished college. And I thought, you know, that's how naive I was.
She was one of the Virginia people, a few people from Virginia were in the sit-ins. What quite a few I'm sure. But I wanted all of them to be in there.
But I didn't live in Virginia. My parents were in California, you know.
So you talked about thinking you're going to change the world. What did you want to change? Well, I thought I know that we're not all going to be a hunky-dory, but I thought, well, it's going to be integration now.
You know, it's not going to. The first thing I did, I remember when we got arrested, we went to a courthouse. And I mean, I'm sorry, went to jail. And they put us in this cell, all of us. And it was smelly.
And I thought, dog, gone in. Not even a clean cell can you go in. And then in the court, the court was segregated. I felt like, am I in hell? What has happened? I mean, even the courts are segregated.
And then I remember a black man came in and he was a drunkard and you could smell him. And I thought, why do the judges have to come in? You know, I'm thinking, just it's going downhill fast.
And I thought, am I losing my mind? You know, you know, horrible. But I just thought, okay, now that we've sat in, we have these attorneys and they're going to go to court and everything is going to be right. And it's not going to be any longer.
But you can change laws, but you can't change people. It comes about through your doing individually.
And that's what kind of process is that?
What do you think?
You know, I think, well, the young kids today, many of them didn't grow up during that era. Thank God. And many of them, if you get angry with anyone, it's angry, not because of a person's color, it's for some other reason.
And I think that's great. Many of the kids are that way today. You know, I mean, you still have, you're going to always have an upper dog and a lower dog. You know.
How long were you at college before the 7th started?
I don't remember. You're asking me difficult questions.
This is the pre-example.
I'm sorry. Really, I don't remember. In fact, I was surprised that it was so important.
Well, this would have been, so the Senate Virginia Union University was, or with Virginia Union University students, was about, I believe about three weeks after the one that, in Greensboro,
they were on February 1st.
And so it would have been one of the early ones, but part of the wave of citizens. Do you know if you were aware of where, you know, other citizens?
Yeah. Why did this come up as a strategy?
Yeah. I don't, honest to Pete. I really don't remember.
But you were aware of the thing you got here.
What about the notion of nonviolence and how you were going to comport yourselves, could potentially be dangerous?
Yeah. I was going to be a nonviolent person. I'm not a violent person anyway, just my mouth, unfortunately.
Yeah. I thought it's not fair to have people hit you.
And you can't really protect yourself. It's really not fair. I think had I been a man, I probably would have been angry and retaliated.
I don't know that, but maybe.
And where's their report?
Did you run into trauma? No. The dogs and things, but it was fine.
When I said it was fine, our citizens were calm compared to some other cities and other cities and states.
What actually happened?
We went downtown several days and we went to Thalhimer's department store and we sat down.
Well, I didn't sit down. I was standing, but being so tall, they pointed me out really intruly.
Because I stand out and I had on high heels shoes too. So that made me over six feet tall.
And they just wouldn't serve us. I mean, it was relatively calm compared to what I've seen on the news and talked with other people.
How many students were there? 34.
And you went where you were arrested right away or did it take you?
We walked. The first day, the first time we weren't the second time we were. We walked from school to downtown.
It was kind of a, I hate to say this, but a jovial mood, you know, a lot of kids walking together.
I guess we're all going to change the world.
I don't know how they felt, but that's the attitude that I had and the feeling that I got.
Or were there songs being sung or anything like that?
Yeah, and don't ask me the name so quickly.
Not only that, I had to learn black culture. Not that I, you know, I had to learn the black songs.
Growing up a Catholic, which I'm no longer growing up a Catholic, you don't know those songs.
I had never heard the black national anthem before in my life.
A lot of things I had to learn. I remember I went to Adam Clayton Powell was a big man.
And he and my uncle worked together too.
And he came to town to talk. And I went to one of his meetings, civil rights meetings.
And in the church, the people clapped and they banged their feet like this and it scared me.
I don't want this on the thing. I had never been in a whole group of black people.
And can you imagine I'm black and I'm scared? I mean, that doesn't make good sense.
But you've never experienced this before.
No.
So you said earlier that when you first got to Virginia, and there's this sort of not liking the black people, not liking the white people?
Did this change for you as really long?
I got a better understanding of what was happening.
But the black people had to live there.
And the white people were only going along with the status quo.
And I know I was getting the hell out of there.
As soon as you could.
Yeah.
And why was that?
Because I didn't like Virginia.
And I shouldn't say that on camera.
Because Virginia has many fine qualities. I have to put that part in here.
I was too immature to really appreciate what was happening.
I was too immature.
Did you ever experience other parts of this outfit and the deep stuff?
No. No. That was enough.
Yeah.
Would you be around a little bit?
But I want to follow this when you finished it.
You graduated.
And then where did you go from there?
School wise?
You said you wanted to get the hell out of here.
Oh, yeah. I went to D.C. My dad lived in DC.
And I had a little boyfriend.
Well, young man, boy friend.
And my mother kept saying, come back to California.
I said, Mama, when I go back, I'm not going back to San Diego.
I don't like San Diego. It's too country.
San Diego is flat.
I said, I'm going home to San Francisco.
She says, Claudette, please come back.
She says, I'll tell you what.
I'll pay your way back.
And if you don't like it, you can go back to D.C., or San Francisco.
Well, I came back and started partying.
I'm a kid. I'm partying.
I was a child.
So I was stuck there for two years.
Another city I didn't like.
Then I moved to L.A.
Because I'm partying in L.A.
I have friends here.
This is doing a summertime.
I love dancing.
And I thought, I'll dance all summer.
Go to all these parties.
And then I'll go up to San Francisco and get a job.
And what did you do for work?
My last job was California Assembly Bill 922,
which is an expulsion counselor for L.A.
Law San Jose Unified School District, L.A.
USDA.
So did you work for the school semester here?
Career.
Well, I taught people working for masters.
You know I have a doctorate in human behavior.
So I taught graduate students career psychology.
California Lutheran University and California Lutheran University.
What did you do?
At California Lutheran University.
So back to California?
Yeah.
Well, my master's at USC.
I'm a California person.
So what?
I do want to ask what he tells about the students.
But let's stay in California for a minute.
Okay.
So what did that experience that you went through there?
But both as a student, it is just experiencing that side of you
and Crowley was kind of different from maybe from where you were raised.
And then going through the sit-ins there and all that and coming back.
What did you take away from that?
What did you bring back to California?
That the will of justice turned slowly, really and truly.
It's slowly, you know.
And I often thought, would I do it again?
Yeah, I would do it again.
I would do it again.
Yeah.
It did hurt me job-wise.
I went for a job in D.C.,
And the guy said, I have to hire you.
But because you made a high score in the exam.
But I don't think you would be happy here.
He says, I see you've been involved in civil rights.
And because I always put down that I have an arrest record.
And then for Los Angeles Unified School District, I took the written exam ten times, never flunked the written.
They flunked me on the training and experience.
So I was working for the county school district before I came to Los Angeles Unified School District.
And I asked the superintendent of the counties, he liked me as a person.
I said, Mr. Tollin, can you find out why they won't hire me in L.A.?"
And he did.
He says, you have an arrest record for sit-in.
And they think you're going to be a problem.
And I finally got in because somebody mistakenly sent me a contract.
I think it was my guardian angel.
I really do.
I think somebody saw what was happening.
I'm just guessing, maybe a black secretary in Santa Piper Out.
You know.
So it's here.
You want to talk more about the sit-ins.
And I guess I don't talk a lot about it because I think in my...
I think I've suppressed that it was uncomfortable.
Very uncomfortable.
And it hurts to this day.
You know.
What is it that's about it, say, think?
Because it hurts because many people's attitude have not changed, you know?
And also, when I see these black kids, not going to school, it hurts me to my heart.
Not voting.
You know, don't they realize they need an education.
They have to vote.
And many of them are not doing it.
And I want to cry.
You know.
I really want to cry.
You told me before we started thinking back to these times, when do you feel very emotional?
I was wondering what exactly we were thinking about.
Yeah.
The whole thing in life, but the way the situation is today.
And also, with Obama being president, many feelings have come to surface.
Many of what other people feel have come to surface in a negative fashion.
And I don't like that.
You know, the screaming out during sessions, calling him names, comparing him to Hitler and so forth.
And I do know you always need a top dog.
I understand that.
And it will be, I mean, if we get rid of race, it'll be size, height.
It will be something.
Color eyes.
You know.
When my brother came back from Switzerland, he was the man behind Henry Kissinger.
And Henry Kissinger and a Henry Kissinger.
He came back and he says, Claudette, you know.
He says, this stuff is BS.
I said, what?
He said, the racial stuff.
He says, we have world problems.
He was really upset.
He says, we have world problems to contend with.
You know.
So you come from a panel of serious achievers.
Yeah.
I do.
With the emphasis on education.
Yeah.
And any insight into that?
No.
Not at all.
I'm glad I did.
Yeah.
And your work in the school district at a counselor, were there racial issues that came up in the industry?
In fact, I was so angry, I wrote a letter, three page type written, a computer written letter.
And they're going to say it's not racial, but it is.
We did expulsions for kids who brought knives, guns, drugs and so forth.
Okay.
We had a hearing.
And if we found this to be so, then we told you you were straight expel or suspended expel.
Which meant you're either kicked out of the school district or you go to a special school.
We had a kid who, without any names, of course, who was involved and very involved in drugs.
But because his parents had money, he was white.
They didn't kick him out.
And I was so angry.
And I was one of three on the committee.
And I told the other two committee people who were white.
I said, you know, he's guilty.
And they said, well, he's going to go to college.
I said, so, well, we judge it on a case by case.
I said, yeah, I said, don't feed that to me.
You know, that's like saying, oh, you're so good, you can do that.
I said, don't do that to me.
I said, the kid is guilty.
So I wrote a letter saying the inner city kids who are not going to go to college
who do the same thing or not as much will be expelled.
So it's there.
No.
Tell me to this.
How did you feel when a woman was elected?
I was elated because he was intelligent.
Not because he was only black.
I have to put black too.
Because he was intelligent, knowledgeable.
And I felt he was going to do the best he could for everyone.
You know, not just black people, everyone.
You can't have someone doing for one group.
And not the whole.
Were you in working with the school district during Boston period?
Yeah.
I was in black.
I was on one of the committees and I asked a question.
I said, why are you only busing the black kids?
And the person who was in charge said, did you hear what I said?
He shut me up.
He says, did you hear what I said?
Right now we're busing the black kids.
And that was it.
And he talked over me.
Yeah.
And that is how it happened.
You know, there are the ones who had to get up early, come home late, you know, drive far.
I know where I lived in LA.
I lived in view park, which had the number one elementary school academically in my area.
Because the people who lived in my area were educators, doctors, lawyers, black people mostly.
And our school was top.
My kids went to private school, went to the French school.
But anyway, they bus the kids from the school and no parent would put a kid on the bus.
They said, why should we bus our kids?
Our kids have had integrated experiences.
They've gone to Europe.
They've, you know, they've been to the stories.
They don't need to go to a white school.
Well, what the school district was was, was take out every other grade.
So you had the bus shed kid away.
Right.
Was that one of the reasons why you sent your kids to private school?
No, I just did.
I sent them to the French school.
I just did.
They ended up at public school eventually.
Oh, they did?
Yeah.
And which school?
You know, Palisades Charter High School?
Yeah.
That's where my sister went.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
And had an okay experience there?
My kids don't see things the way I see things anyway.
Well, I mean, they have experienced my son used to be vice president of, uh, Fredo, uh,
Dr. Pepper in marketing.
Um, and before that, it was with Fredo Lays in marketing.
And I don't want to say anything about different corporations.
So I won't name the corporation, but he had a glass ceiling also, which, you know,
did you talk as you were raising your own children?
Did you talk to them at the experiences that you would have?
I did not.
No.
You know, my mother didn't tell me, well, she would show me these history books.
And I would see and read in the history books.
But she didn't want to prejudice me against people, which I can appreciate.
And I didn't want to do that to my children either.
I know I took them out of school, uh, an ice date home that day and took on Martin Luther King's birthday.
I would take them to the museum, you know.
That was the big black thing that we did, I guess.
Before it was a national holiday, you know.
Right.
What about getting positive, which is a black people in schools?
It's like that wasn't happening for your children?
You know, I don't think any more than I got.
Yeah.
Because I don't think so.
No, I was on the book committee with Los Angeles Unified School District and I said, why is this
page with the black person on it at the end of the chapter?
And it was myth-hoofling.
Because when we send the books down south, we tear that page out,
but we don't include that page.
I said, but I've read the chapter and it has nothing to do with the chapter.
I said, you're just stuck a black person in there to sell your book.
You know.
Yeah.
I'm going to jump to this for the big question, I guess, which is.
Oh, this is reflecting on this.
It's no really.
Yeah, well, my reflection is not good.
Right.
Because the project that we're working on is on the civil rights.
Civil rights.
Right.
And I'm just curious, what is the civil rights movement to you?
Because I know it can be defined in different ways.
And I'm sort of interested being the experiences that you had.
Whether you see yourself as part of it, is it still going on?
What is the civil rights movement?
I think today the kids, especially in L.A., they're not concerned about civil rights.
It's La La Land.
What shoes do you have on, what purse, what brand name?
Whether you can rap play ball or basketball or football or jewelry or a car.
It's a different story and that's black, white, green, or yellow.
You know, regardless of the race or they're involved in superficial things that won't last,
I don't think.
To me, you know, I moved up here and I kept my house in L.A.,
I said, in case they burn across them, they mean white people.
Burn across on my lawn.
I'm moving.
I'm too old to fight now.
You know?
I'm moving.
And of course, they did not.
They white people did not.
You thought that might have, where did Ohio help?
You thought that might happen?
Yeah, because I had read in the paper, is that a black kid in high school had nigger printed on her locker in Ohio.
Not too long ago.
Just before we moved up, which wasn't too long ago, we've been here nine years.
And did that surprise, I mean, so hearing about an overt incident or racism like that,
and I don't know, a little time like, oh, hi, did that surprise you or is that sort of,
no, it didn't surprise me.
I didn't expect it, but I didn't surprise me.
Yeah.
And we talked about this a little bit on camera, but I wonder if you could tell me what,
what life is like in a town like this for an African person?
I guess it's like anything for any white person.
I mean, it's a small town that closes up when the sun goes down.
It has one block of downtowns.
It has a lot of boutiques that are very expensive, and a lot of little restaurants.
It has a theater that gets first-class movies because of all the directors that live here.
It has two live theaters.
And one theater, the local people play in, and the other theater, I don't know who plays.
I don't go to them anymore.
I go to LA.
The club's closed.
You can go in a club and take your child and your dog.
There's one club next to the movie, and it's a nice little place, you know.
It's nice.
Yeah, there are walking trails and horse trails.
And the helicopters are not ghetto copters.
They are private helicopters.
That was one thing I have to just say that it gave us a beer just in Los Angeles.
I hadn't been in Los Angeles for 20 years.
It was something else to see the sky full of helicopters at Camp Nou.
That's right.
I knew how to work the projects, and if I had to go in them, I knew if the helicopters were overhead.
If it's too late in the day, you don't go in, you know.
So did you do any of your jobs?
Did you do home visits?
Not as an expulsion counselor, but before that, I was making home calls.
As a job at another counselor, PSA, pupil services, and I tend, which expulsion was under that PSA, but it was a different...
I don't know how many jobs under PSA.
I would make home calls, but you learn how to make home calls, you know.
You learn when you knew on what we call Mother's Day when the people get their welfare checks, you don't go in.
Different days, and things, you know.
What happened on welfare check day?
The people weren't going to be home. They're busy.
Cool.
So do you think, again, this is better?
Yes, I know because that's what you're doing.
Yeah.
What do you think we are now, or how do you feel about where we are?
I thought about that.
I think they say the more things change, the more they stay the same.
I think things are, we have code words now, you know.
It's like living in California now. It's covert.
So, excuse me.
But my neighbor, when we go out to eat, we're going out to eat next Monday, four of us.
My neighbor let me, oh, when I moved in here, my neighbor sent me a pie, which I thought was very nice.
In another neighbor gave me some fruit.
Anyway, my neighbor said, oh, I'm from some southern state.
And she said it again to let me know, I think, that, hey, I'm okay.
I'm a human being, you know.
Because she told me that.
Yeah.
I didn't answer your question.
And I have pondered that question, where are we today?
Yeah, the black kids don't have to go into education, social work, ministry, whatever the jobs were that we could get.
If you notice you ask an old person like me, I'm 73, what did you do?
They're all in education.
Because that's the only thing we could do.
All the black men were at the post office, you know, with degrees.
Today you can get other jobs, fortunately.
I don't know how high you're going, but you can get other jobs.
So, let me ask about your graphics and experience.
Women in your program with other black students in your program.
USC didn't have many blacks, but, you know, there were other blacks.
And USC, you had a few.
A few. You didn't know not many.
And the experience was fine.
I didn't feel any racism at all.
I just, and from that experience that you had, Virginia, you knew you were still thinking, especially the city and experience.
Did you, do that come back to you that actually did you draw on that experience at all and lay the part of your own?
Draw on it in which way?
I don't know. I would just leave it open to you.
There were times that that came back to you, or that you took something from that experience,
that made an influence where you, what you did later.
I think it opened me to be more respectful in my mind of people of different cultures.
I call Richmond a different culture.
To be respectful and to appreciate differences, we all can't be alike.
And to appreciate where I am at the moment.
At that time, I was so, my God, I can't stand Richmond.
I was the people, they're backwards. I'm judging. They weren't backwards. I was backwards.
They were fine.
What was it like for you going back to the reunion?
Richmond hasn't changed. It still, it looks the same to me.
And yet they said, I don't know.
When I saw downtown, I said, my gosh, this place is the same.
I like visiting, but I'm going to live in California. I'm sure they're glad I'm here.
Would you send your own children to the predominantly white colleges?
My son went to Union, but he didn't like it. He says, Mom, I can't take it. It's too country.
But he did go to Morehouse.
Oh, he did?
Yeah, for undergrad.
And then that school in Carolina, I told you for for grad.
Was that going to a, to a, historically, back college, that's something that you thought might be important?
I wanted both my children to go. But as I told you, my daughter was on a 6-15, I think, when she started.
She was too young.
Yeah.
And my son, I think, was 16 or 17 yet.
You know, too young.
So they went to college, you know.
But he was ready.
Yeah.
She said she was too mature, immature.
But she knew she was.
Don't you want to switch one?
Yeah.
Right.
What did I take out of it?
Well, as I said, I really had my eyes opened when I went to the reunion 50th, the 50th year reunion for the sit-in people.
And I had thought about it too about how I was so judgmental.
I remember an old black lady saying to me, honey, why are you guys marching for this?
You need to march for better jobs.
And I thought, are you a silly old lady?
She must have been every bit of 50.
You know, why are you asking me this silly question?
I didn't say that to her, but I was thinking that, or we're not ready yet.
I don't think, but when are you going to be ready?
Yeah.
So you really, you were involved in the very early sit-in.
And did you, and left for the meeting, not too long after that?
Well, I graduated in the 62.
Okay.
So a couple more years.
Yeah.
Did you follow what was going on in either back enrichment or in other parts of the South?
Yeah, oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, definitely.
Yeah, in fact, I was here, which is not quite the sit-ins, but the March on Washington, I was here.
And I told my husband, gee, I want to go to the March on Washington.
I really did.
You know, and my brother would keep me informed.
He says, Claudette, today, people are meeting at the White House in planning strategy with President John F. Kennedy.
I say, you're kidding.
He says, yeah.
So, yeah.
You know, I'm sorry, I can't do more.
You know, when you get old, I swear, your mind, they say your mind is the first thing to go.
It's going.
I don't know.
I don't know what you're supposed to do.
Just to follow on that, I was thinking of, do you remember your reactions to the legislation that I passed?
So, right to act, the voting rights act.
I was extremely happy.
Of course, it doesn't take much to make me happy, though.
How does that relate to what we were saying before about, maybe you can change rules, but can you change parts of the mind?
Did you think that those, why did you think those acts were important?
Well, you know, well, as I said, first of all, you have to educate people.
And maybe, hopefully, through education, people will change their way of thinking, hopefully.
Maybe people will get out to vote if they can, if they don't put, they, I keep saying they, the party said be, black or white,
put stumbling blocks in the way, hopefully.
You have so many people that don't care.
So, what difference does my vote make?
It's not going to change anything anyway.
I remember the situation just in the last few days where it seems like the voting rights act might be challenging.
What was your reaction to that?
Good. Let's take it all the way up.
You see what happens. Good. Good.
Good. Yeah.
Yeah, that's fine.
As my uncle and my aunt, let's have a good old fight.
My uncle and aunt love knock them down fights legally.
Yeah.
Oh, that brings one out of the question, which was how did your family react about your involvement in the city?
Well, I called my uncle and he used to call me screwball.
He said screwball, talk to Martin A. Martin.
That was the attorney handling it.
That was his friend.
And I talked to attorney Martin.
I said, my uncle told me to talk to you.
He said, who's your uncle? I said, Jay Hugo, Matt.
He said, oh, I know him.
I said, he says for you to take care of me.
He says, okay, I will.
And I felt very happy and giddy about the city.
I didn't, it was depressing the whole, as I said, the whole thing of being in that patty wagon.
It was not clean.
And then being in the jail wasn't clean.
And then the courtroom was segregated.
And it was smelly.
And the guy who came in was nasty and smelly.
I just thought, I'm losing my mind.
This is hell.
I really thought I didn't know what hell was at that time.
But you said you were also giddy.
I was giddy because I'm changing the world.
It's going to change now.
I'm going to court.
It's going to change.
We're all going to be happy.
And it's going to be black people are going to stand up.
And the white people are going to be okay.
I mean, we're not going to sit down and eat ice cream together.
But at least you're going to respect that I can sit down here.
So you got the support of your uncle?
Oh, yeah.
And my aunt, my aunt called me from New York.
She said, yeah.
Were there others that were fearful for you?
No, nobody.
Nobody.
My mother, my stepfather, nobody.
Now, not at all.
So what was the reaction you got?
They were very happy.
And my uncle says, Claudette,
things are not going to change as fast as you think.
It takes time.
Did you believe him?
Yeah, because I knew he was doing that in Norfolk.
Yeah, I believe too.
Do you feel that the family that you came from prepared you for?
What were you going to involve in it in some way?
I'm sure.
Without knowing it, you give your children their values.
Covertly and overtly, both ways.
Yeah.
In fact, my mother always said, the squeaky will gets the attention
whether it's bad or good.
So I guess I was a squeaky will.
And have you stayed in touch with people from Virginia?
You went to the reunion?
No.
I saw only Charles.
And that was by mistake.
Well, not by mistake.
I saw him on TV doing black history month.
And I said, that's Charles and I went online and found him.
And had you been aware of what he had been doing all these years?
No.
What was your life?
What was your life when you were in?
He was my boyfriend.
Oh, come on.
He was a Baptist minister.
And at that time, I was a pseudo Catholic.
I went to Catholic Church in Richmond.
And I knelt down and everyone came in the pew.
They looked over and saw me and got up and laughed.
And I said, now my faith is not that good to start out with.
And you guys are not helping it any.
I'm thinking, you know.
And people are going to hate me when I say this because I'm spiritual now.
Whatever that means.
So I told the priest after Mass.
I said, you know, people came in when I say people, white people.
People came in the pew where I was.
And they looked over and saw me and got up and laughed.
I said, then an old lady came.
There was no place to sit.
And she came late and saw me.
She knelt down beside me.
Then she saw me and got up and laughed.
He says, my child pray for her.
And I thought, well, I'm not going to church anymore.
I have to pray for people and you can't tell them.
You know, doing a Mass.
Yeah.
No, it's the last time you went to that church.
And as I said, my faith wasn't too strong anyway.
So it didn't take much to make it go.
So what was your own Charles Charade like?
He was nice.
I would go with him when he preached down in the country.
Like an intern preaching at these country churches.
And he used to say, darn, you Catholic girl.
He would call me a Catholic girl.
Yeah.
When I say boyfriend, girlfriend, we weren't tight, tight,
but we were boyfriend, girlfriend.
Yeah.
And had you seen preaching like that before?
I went with my girlfriend in San Francisco to two or three churches.
But they weren't emotional, you know?
But they did sing songs.
I mean, you know, songs with a beat to it.
Yeah.
I like that now.
I don't know the beat.
Now you need to find your El Haido.
Well, no.
No.
You can get it on YouTube.
Yeah.
What do you have any other questions?
No, I've never been to a lot of Brown.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
My memory is really bad.
I am so sorry.
You did mention that it was very emotional time.
What was the access to made so emotional?
Well, I felt like I wanted to cry because when I think about what has been
been happening in the past and what is happening now, I'm not too far.
I'm not too sure that we're that far from the past and now with things that
I went online to see the insults that were hold at Obama.
And I had to stop because there were so very many of them.
And all of them, some of them are right out in his face.
But why?
I used to think the poor of the person was the more they would hold insults.
But that's not true.
They can have 10 PhDs and do the same thing.
And as I said, I want to cry about my black children not voting.
White kids too don't vote, unfortunately.
Not going to school.
Drugs are rampant.
Oh, hi has a big drug problem.
What are we doing?
What are we rearing today?
Where are we going?
You're not voting mostly.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't think we're obviously through this project where in some way so,
we're also taking stock.
It's a time to reflect.
Not only on what was done and sit into the 19th and 16th, but where are we?
Sometimes I don't want to.
Reflect.
I told, because it's uncomfortable.
I told my husband, I said, you know, I'm not filling this paper out before I go to bed.
Because I won't be able to sleep.
When I put my uncle down in my aunt, down thinking about the things they were involved in and so forth.
What do you think about how they would respond?
No, I know what they went through.
You know.
I did tell you, maybe my aunt integrated the bus line, a greyhound bus line,
and the courts had already said it should be not separate but equal together.
And they did not integrate it.
It was in Virginia.
And my aunt told my mother was visiting.
My aunt told my mother and another sister, come on, we're going to go to D.C. from Virginia.
And we're going by bus.
And my mother says, why?
Let's drive.
And my aunt said, no, we're going by bus.
Because we don't take the greyhound.
Anyway, it took the greyhound and my aunt got off.
She says, you keep going to D.C.
Call Hugo, that's my uncle, and call Paul, Adam Clayton Powell,
because I'm going to get arrested.
And she did, because she said in the white section, but the courts made them obey the law.
You know.
That was something that surprised me about the movement, was how much, once the law was in effect,
how much testing of the law had to be done all over the country?
Right.
Yeah.
In fact, something was on the news recently about some little southern town,
that I don't know what it was.
Did you see it?
I missed it.
Oh.
Yeah.
But I know even here in California, I know not to go in some cities.
To that, really.
Heck, yes.
Yeah.
Because you know what kinds of things do you think would happen?
Well, for example, I was going to a city, and I didn't want to name the city.
And I passed to a little place, Canyon Country, down that way.
And I got lost before I had the GPS.
And my daughter was with me.
I said, we can't stop at that little club there.
I said, it looks like a little red net club.
We can't stop there.
I said, do you know what I'm talking about?
She says, mom, I know.
I don't know what she knows.
She said she knows.
And because you can fill it, you know?
And that's something that, in some ways, hasn't changed.
I mean, I'm sure you could sense those places throughout your life.
Right.
And when you intellectualize it, you get in trouble.
You have to fill it in your gut and go with your gut.
Yeah.
Well, that's just it.
You can decide a lot of things in what's for it.
Right.
But the feelings are another whole thing.
Absolutely.
And that's true for man, period, in everything he does.
You know, regardless of race.
You know.
And in some way, you rely on a community, right?
And you can navigate these things.
And some of it's difficult.
I would think difficult in a place like Ohio.
The community isn't that large.
No.
But I felt it in Ohio.
But I move on.
You know, you don't have to like me.
That's fine.
For it.
Yeah.
Do you remember when they had The Negro Motorist Green Book?
No, I know.
Oh, you're too young.
What's that?
When you traveled, we were little.
I was little.
And my parents used to go to AAA and get, you know,
how they draw the map for you.
Well, they had a special book for black people,
where you could stay.
Yeah.
Because when we traveled, my parents sometimes would stop at a black person's house.
And say, do you know where black people can stay when we traveled down south?
And they would say, Mrs. Jones has a room.
And we would go there, the stay overnight.
Yes.
Those are kind of things that people can't even imagine now.
You know?
Yeah.
You have people.
I mean, there are people I talk with.
They seem like grownups and they were given born.
Right.
They don't have a 2,000 year old.
Yeah, they have no idea.
Yeah.
That's true.
But it also says a lot about, I mean, essentially,
a triple A sort of formalized.
It processes a lot about how people adapt and take care of each other.
You know, that you could stop at someone's house and put you on.
Yeah.
I mean, Mrs. Jones did put a trap word.
On the flip side, integration closed many black people's businesses.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Peg Leg Bates had a place in the upper New York.
I can't think of what it's called.
People back east know it.
And I heard that the black people used to go there and stay overnight and have a good time.
And it closed when integration happened.
Many of the black hotels and other places closed.
Yeah.
Are there other things that you think the black community lost during the integration?
I think some of the black kids don't know who they are, whatever that means, who they are.
Yeah.
You know, my girlfriend is married to a Mexican fellow.
And her kids told her, Mom, oh, you just think that because you're black.
And, yeah, they don't know anything about her, really.
Yeah.
That also means they don't identify.
Right.
Yeah.
We hear a lot of stories of, in some ways, stories of laws or even a nest challenge for.
A good old day.
Oh, black school.
Yeah.
Looking at it as the little days, even, of course, there was a lot of.
For that.
Right.
Yeah.
You know, speaking of black, I have written the L.A. Times and various other newspapers about not capitalizing the word black.
And I spelled it out why I felt it should be.
I said, white is generic.
Black is not.
When you say black, you only mean an American from Africa.
You don't mean a Jamaican.
You don't mean a Puerto Rican.
You only mean a person in America who is black.
So it should be capitalized.
And I feel that it's in and insult when you see in the papers different groups of people and then a lower case letter of a black.
You know.
Yeah.
I wrote a letter.
Oh, also in that package, I have a letter that I wrote to this local paper and I'm surprised they printed it.
They talked about two black women doing something fraudulent and it should you see them call the police.
So I wrote them a long letter.
I said, you named two black women.
You have made it dangerous for me to walk downtown.
No description.
That's it.
That was the only description.
Yeah, it's in that packet.
Yeah.
Have you written any other letters to the editor over the years or other issues that got under your schedule?
Only about the black issue have I written to the very, I wrote it to the LA Times and I'm always writing letters.
Well, but I write good letters to compliment people when they should be.
I felt I was writing my bicycle and I turned the corner too fast and for the first time I didn't have my helmet on and I hit my head on the fire hydrant around the corner.
And I'm down there crying like an ugly ugly thing just crying.
And I look uglier than ugly when I cry.
And two men got out of their truck and they said, are you okay?
I said, oh no, I'm crying.
Why man held my hand as well?
Then I thought, oh god, you're looking uglier.
Stop crying.
So I stopped crying.
But you know, there were two white men helping a black lady or two men helping a female for that matter.
Yeah.
So I haven't felt anything.
Oh, I mean, I'm sure they're.
As I said, if I feel anything, I move on.
I might be wrapping up here.
Do you think about that?
You know, what you did at Virginia Union University and being part of this protest.
As something very historic, you did it being a participant.
I do now.
I didn't think it was.
I thought it was something we were doing.
You know, it was one of many people across the country.
But I didn't realize it until afterwards.
In fact, I didn't realize it until I was at a school.
And I was in the library.
And the lady says, Dr. Grinnell, do you know anything about the Civil Rights Movement?
And I said, yeah, I do.
I said, I was in it.
She says, you were?
Oh, no, not a big deal.
You know, then I realized she's young.
She's a young teacher.
And that's when it hit me.
I guess it was a big deal.
Yeah.
That's a great finish in one, I think.
Oh, thank you.
Well, it wasn't a deal.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, let me just ask you, was there anything that I didn't ask that you thought I might ask or that I should have asked?
No, I'll think of it later on, but it probably won't be important anyway.
So, no.
Well, thank you so much.
But thank you.
I appreciate it.
And I'll tell you what you have to do while you're here since I made a cake for you guys.
You have to eat it.
I made a pound cake.
Well, whether you like it or not.
You have to take off.
Okay.
You've done your sacrifice.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.